[Music]
that consciousness Revo is often
misunderstood because you know what by
reference but it's difficult to know it
back content what you really mean by
free though a lot of people will
immediately feel that free will is
related to whether the universe is
deterministic or probabilistic and the
physics has some ideas about that which
change over now then it's not part of
our experience and I don't think it
makes a difference if the universe
forces you randomly to do things or
deterministically the important thing
seems to me that in free will you are
responsible for your actions and
responsibility is a social interface for
instance if I am told that if I do X I
go to prison and this changes my
decision to whether or not to do X
I'm obviously responsible for my
decision because it wasn't appeal to my
responsibility in some sense or likewise
if I do a certain thing that it causes
harm to other people and they don't what
that harm to happen it influences my
decision the deciduous course of
decision-making that the I would call
it's a free will decision will of the
representation that my nervous system at
any level of its functioning has raised
the motive to an intention it has
committed to a particular kind of goal
and get integrated into the story of
myself this protocol that I experienced
of as myself and this world and that was
what I experienced as well as a real
decision in this decision is free and in
as much as this decision can be
influenced by this course so to me for
evil is a social notion it means that
this interface also of social
interaction of discourse of thinking
about things about the interface of
knowledge language conceptual thought as
well as and for that disposition if you
have a decision in which it doesn't play
a role for instance because you are
addicted to something and you cannot
stop doing it even if you want to then
the decision I would say is not free I
grew up in eastern Germany maybe with
communist Eastern Germany and it was a
very weird adding auditer country a
country that believed in stories about
how the world works that I as a nerd
thought are obviously not quite true I
had difficulty believing the office
stories about how the world works it was
like some weird kind of religion and
then the wall came down and it didn't
surprise me in the least
and then we entered a new dream a new
shared model of the world it was not
quite true and I realized that most
people now fall for this new model it
was very interesting for to see this for
me and if you look for instance at the
US the majority of u.s. Americans do not
believe in the theory of evolution
despite all the evidence to the contrary
the majority of people are on this
planet are religious even though that
doesn't seem to be very good evidence
for a multitude of creator gods and so
on in my view at least and if it existed
if a Creator God existed it would be
very hard for me to understand why this
Creator God really does care about
whether I worship it or all these things
that we attribute to create a gods by
religion so it's very hard for me in
some sense to intuitively understand why
humans are religious and why humans are
ideological but I think now over the
years that this is not a bug it's a
feature humans are a programmable
species religions and ideologies are
operating systems for societies there
has been so throughout most of our
history and this idea that we can build
society based on rational arguments is
very very recent and very novel and it's
not entirely clear if it really works
but it's clear that we cannot really
build societies on conflicting
ideologies that are at war with each
other in the past that has led to
situations where the ideologies solve
the problems by killing the unbelievers
or the religions did the same thing and
we all agree that is not what we want to
have we want to have an open society
pluralistic society a non-violent
tolerant society but still one where
people work together and cooperate up
and this ability to wake up into a
shared dream in which people believe
things because their neighbors believe
them has been a very powerful feature
that's probably the reason why we were
able to build our scale societies we
have to understand that when people
cooperate they're very often in what we
call a prisoner's dilemma a situation
and they're in order to achieve
the greatest good you have to give up
something for yourself even in a
situation where that is in some sense
bit irrational because if everybody else
is not doing it you're going to be worse
off and for these prisoners dilemmas we
have various solutions the easy solution
is to have a reputation system you
basically keep track of who did what
when and you make sure that only the
good guys get cookies in the future and
the problem is that these reputation
systems do not scale if you have too
many people in your tribe or your family
or any other lych you just do strike off
who did what when and you cannot really
synchronize it by talking about it so
after a couple hundred individuals the
reputation system doesn't work very well
it also doesn't really work if you are
not looking so if nobody is doing the
surveillance how do you make sure that
nobody is defecting and stealing stuff
from the fridge of your tribe right so
what do we do we evolve the ability to
be normative the ability or the need to
be good and just need to be good this
need to follow internalized norms this
need to serve sacred principles it's
something that it's probably a feature
that is ingrained into our genetic
makeup and of course this alone would
not be good enough because goodness is
like an arbitrary vector in value space
people also have a need to synchronize
what's good so people will try to feel
what's good in their in-group it works
by empathy empathy it's a primary mode
in which we transmit norms if you dress
up somebody as an authority as a priest
as a professor as a pop star is a
politician and this person says a
certain thing this conviction and people
see that others believe it they start
believing it themselves and it's
obviously very useful to do this there's
almost never a situation but it's useful
to have an opinion that is different
from the opinion of your boss so this is
the ability that you got it means that
people perform the same things that they
follow the same rules regardless of the
size of the group this makes it possible
to build agricultural societies with
hundreds of thousands of individuals and
then millions of individuals it makes it
possible that this agricultural society
people that specialize on different
foods and different traits and different
materials and different crafts and so on
and produce all the multitude of tasks
and tools that we need to get an
agricultural society to run and be able
to out-compete the pneumatic societies
and I think the reason by Homo sapiens
is the only hominid species that's left
because we all computed them all they
were in the same competitive niche and
the various species that was
programmable that was able to coordinate
our cherry large group of individuals
that was very powerful it just turns out
that this mode of tribal organization is
not sufficient for the world that we
live in now
[Music]